-20h,
voici notre estimation
du résultat du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle.
En tête, Jacques Chirac,
20 % des voix.
Enorme surprise, Jean-Marie Le Pen
semble devoir être le second,
avec 17 % des voix.
-L'élection présidentielle de 2002
arrive après 5 ans de cohabitation
entre le Premier ministre socialiste
Lionel Jospin
et le président, issu du RPR,
Jacques Chirac.
Tous deux sont donnés favoris
tout au long de la campagne.
Le climat politique
est tendu,
sur fond d'affaires judiciaires
et dans un paysage politique éclaté.
-Quel est votre premier commentaire,
M. Le Pen,
après l'énoncé de ces chiffres ?
-Je crois
que c'est une grande défaite
des deux leaders
de l'établissement.
-Le résultat de ce premier tour
du 21 avril 2002
est inédit
dans la vie politique française,
puisqu'un candidat classé
à l'extrême droite
se qualifie
pour le second tour
d'une élection présidentielle.
-Pour nous,
militants, on a vu ça
comme une récompense extraordinaire
après tant d'années de lutte.
C'était une lutte politique.
-C'est quand même un peu
une surprise.
Curieusement,
celui qui l'avait le mieux prédit,
c'est Le Pen lui-même.
15 jours avant l'élection,
nous sommes réunis
en bureau politique
du Front national,
et il dit :
"Il faut préparer un deuxième tour,
je sens un frémissement,
"et je pense
qu'il n'est pas impossible
"que je sois au deuxième tour."
-N'ayez pas peur...
-La surprise est
d'autant plus grande
que le Front national
de Jean-Marie Le Pen
est très affaibli.
Depuis sa scission en 1998,
le parti est au point mort.
La plupart de ses cadres
ont quitté le navire.
-Quand Jean-Marie Le Pen
arrive au second tour
à la présidentielle,
il est à la tête
d'un micro groupuscule,
pauvre, avec personne.
C'est totalement la demande sociale,
la demande des électeurs,
qui le propulse au second tour.
-Tout le monde reçoit à ce moment-là
un coup de massue sur la tête.
Le Pen sera au second tour.
Personne ne veut y croire.
Musique intrigante
...
-Qui est cet homme lucide à la tête
de l'extrême droite française
qui arrive au second tour
de la présidentielle de 2002 ?
Souhaite-t-il vraiment
prendre le pouvoir ?
Est-il en mesure de l'exercer ?
D'où vient-il ?
Quelle est sa personnalité ?
-On considère
que les gens de caractère
sont des gens
qui ont mauvais caractère
et qui tranchent
sur la platitude générale.
Non, je pense bien sûr
que les difficultés de la vie
m'ont forgé,
comme tous les êtres humains.
-Jean Louis Marie Le Pen est
le fils unique de Jean Le Pen,
marin-pêcheur,
conseiller municipal
de La Trinité-sur-Mer,
et d'Anne-Marie Hervé,
fille de paysans.
Son père trouve la mort
à bord du chalutier
quand le bateau,
qui pêchait,
saute sur une mine
remontée dans son chalut,
le 22 août 1942.
-Un jour, un Allemand est arrivé
devant la porte,
et il a dit :
"Madame, gros malheur,
la guerre,
"M. Le Pen mort."
Voilà.
Et il est parti.
C'était une bombe
qui nous éclatait en pleine figure.
-A ce moment-là,
il devient l'homme de la famille.
Il garde le fusil de son père,
un pistolet aussi,
qu'il cache dans le grenier,
avec le drapeau français.
Ca explique aussi son côté
- je dirais - très patriote.
Dans "patrie",
il y a "père".
-Pour lui, la nation, c'est le cadre
qui va faire la famille.
Donc, on ne peut pas comprendre
le personnage
sans cette enfance
et sans le fait
que, montant à Paris
faire les études,
il va devenir
un jeune travailleur.
Il y a cet aspect-là
- travail, famille, patrie -
dès son enfance.
-Jeune diplômé, voyant poindre
la défaite française en Indochine,
il s'engage dans l'armée
et s'y rend en 1954,
où il sert comme sous-lieutenant.
-Quand je suis en doctorat,
je pense que la vie
ne se déroule pas ici.
C'est ailleurs.
Je pense
que c'est notamment en Asie,
et je m'engage.
Je demande à partir
dans les parachutistes
de la Légion étrangère.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il voulait défendre ?
Est-ce que c'était l'empire,
ou est-ce que c'était pas plutôt
des jeunes qui avaient encore
le poids de l'humiliation
de la France en 1940 sur le coeur ?
-A son retour d'Indochine,
en 1955,
Le Pen devient président
des Jeunes indépendants de Paris
et délégué général de l'Union
de défense de la jeunesse française.
Présenté à Pierre Poujade,
il devient délégué national
de l'Union de défense
des commerçants et artisans,
UDCA.
Il est placé à la tête
de la liste aux législatives
dans la première circonscription
de la Seine.
-La France, à ce moment-là,
est traversée
par un courant contestataire
qui ressemble un peu
à celui des gilets jaunes,
si on veut,
d'origine professionnelle,
l'Union de défense
des commerçants et des artisans.
-Aujourd'hui,
ça semble pas grand-chose,
les artisans et les commerçants,
il en reste,
mais pas des millions.
A l'époque, c'était,
avec les paysans,
le gros
de la population française.
Donc,
c'est une classe sociale énorme
qui sent qu'elle est menacée.
-La vague poujadiste
lui permet d'obtenir
quelque 36 000 voix, soit 7,8 %
des suffrages exprimés.
Grâce au système
de la proportionnelle,
Jean-Marie Le Pen
est élu à l'Assemblée nationale
à l'âge de 27 ans.
-Le Pen,
brillant orateur,
très jeune, va s'insérer là-dedans
et réussir très bien.
Ce sera le plus grand orateur
du groupe poujadiste
à l'Assemblée nationale.
-En octobre 1956,
la guerre d'Algérie fait rage.
Il quitte pour six mois
les bancs de l'Assemblée
pour s'engager
dans son ancienne unité,
où il participe
comme chef de section
au débarquement en Egypte,
à Suez,
puis à la bataille d'Alger.
-Moi, comme toutes
les forces politiques françaises,
à part le Parti Communiste,
j'étais pour l'Algérie française.
-Encore une fois,
un acte haut en couleur,
un peu genre Le Pen,
mais encore une fois courageux.
-Cet engagement lui vaut
d'être récompensé
de la croix de la Valeur militaire
par le général Massu,
mais aussi, une décennie plus tard,
d'accusations d'actes de torture.
-Lui, son propos, c'est :
"J'ai défendu l'usage de la torture,
"qui me paraissait légitime
dans la guerre,
"mais je ne l'ai pas pratiquée."
Les biographes qui ont travaillé
sur son cas
n'ont pas non plus trouvé d'éléments
qui permettent de dire
qu'il l'a fait
ou qu'il ne l'a pas fait.
-Des accusations jamais étayées,
et en novembre 1958,
sous l'étiquette
Indépendants de Paris
du centre national
des indépendants et paysans,
Jean-Marie Le Pen est réélu député.
A l'Assemblée,
il multiplie les prises de position
pour l'Algérie française
et il est entendu en novembre 1961
par la police,
après être intervenu
lors d'un meeting
où sont ovationnés l'OAS,
une organisation terroriste
pro-Algérie française,
et le général félon Raoul Salan.
Le Pen est contacté
pour faire partie de l'OAS.
-Cette conspiration était
tout simplement mal ficelée.
Sans doute Jean-Marie Le Pen
l'a-t-il senti, à l'époque,
pensant sans doute,
par ailleurs,
qu'étant parlementaire,
il avait peut-être d'autres moyens
de servir la cause
de l'Algérie française
que de rentrer dans la conspiration.
-J'ai toujours refusé de m'engager
dans des structures
où j'étais obligé d'obéir à des gens
que je ne connaissais pas.
-Candidat à sa réélection
dans la 3e circonscription
de la Seine
aux élections législatives de 1962,
il est défait
dans le cadre d'une triangulaire
remportée par un candidat gaulliste.
Dès 1963,
il est nommé directeur de campagne
de l'avocat d'extrême droite
Jean-Louis Tixier-Vignancour,
en vue de la présidentielle
de 1965.
-Il s'engage
derrière Tixier-Vignancour,
parce qu'il connaît
Tixier-Vignancour
et qu'il apprécie cet homme,
qui a défendu pas mal
de proscrits
de l'épuration, d'abord,
et de partisans
de l'Algérie française, ensuite.
-La France avait
un défaut absolu
de présence politique
sur sa droite.
Le CNIP, l'Organisation indépendante
et paysanne,
occupait le terrain
disons des modérés,
mais la France manquait,
à mon sens,
d'une voix
pour défendre
son identité, sa fierté,
sa personnalité.
-Il y a une opportunité
professionnelle à saisir.
Il n'est plus parlementaire.
Et puis, il y a aussi le fait
qu'il a un talent d'organisateur.
-Il participe à la fondation
des comités Tixier-Vignancour,
dont il est le secrétaire général
de 1964 à 1966.
*-Si vous le voulez,
nous pouvons battre de Gaulle
ensemble.
-Pendant tout l'été 1965,
il organise
une campagne politique originale
et décalée,
pour l'époque.
-Il est organisateur
de la campagne Tixier-Vignancour,
de ce qu'on a appelé
"la caravane Tixier-Vignancour",
qui sillonnait
les plages de France en plein été
pour tenter
de rameuter des électeurs.
-De cette campagne présidentielle,
il tire de nombreuses leçons.
-Ca m'a donné l'expérience
de la conduite
d'un mouvement politique,
la nécessité
de l'implantation locale,
territoriale,
l'organisation hiérarchique
du mouvement...
-Mais rien ne se passe comme prévu.
Il rompt finalement
avec Tixier-Vignancour à la suite
du scrutin présidentiel,
lui reprochant notamment
un manque d'autorité politique.
-Hier amis
C'était l'aventure
-Après un nouvel échec
aux législatives de 1968,
Le Pen se retrouve sans travail
et sans famille politique.
Il se lance alors dans l'édition
de disques documentaires,
dont une partie du catalogue
est plutôt sulfureuse.
-Amis
La France nous attend.
-Il fallait aussi
que je gagne ma vie.
J'ai fondé une maison
de production de disques,
historiques et documentaires,
qui a atteint
une certaine notoriété,
puisque j'ai même eu
un Grand Prix du disque,
alors que j'étais pas persona grata
dans les milieux du showbiz,
c'est rien de le dire,
ni dans les autres.
-Il galérait, Jean-Marie Le Pen,
financièrement.
Il tâtonnait pas idéologiquement,
parce que...
Quand on ouvre
les catalogues de la Serp,
on voit bien déjà
quelles sont ses orientations.
Je pense par exemple
à certains disques
d'anciens Waffen-SS
qui ont été édités,
il a été condamné aussi
pour une publication...
Il est dans son bain.
-A la fin des années 60,
de nombreux groupuscules
d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite
font de l'agitprop dans les rues
des grandes villes françaises.
A l'extrême droite,
environ 150 militants créent,
en décembre 1969,
un mouvement appelé Ordre nouveau.
-C'est des néofascistes déclarés.
Dans leur programme de 70,
ils proposent un Etat fasciste,
avec l'interdiction des partis
et des syndicats.
La croix celtique
est leur emblème,
ils pratiquent le salut fasciste
et la violence à grande échelle.
Ils sont dissous pour violence.
-Le credo d'Ordre nouveau était :
la renaissance du patriotisme,
la promotion
d'une hiérarchie des valeurs
ainsi que la restauration familiale
et éducative.
L'objectif proclamé
était de constituer l'ossature
d'un futur parti politique
ayant vocation à rassembler
l'opposition nationaliste de droite
et de participer aux élections.
-Ils se cherchent une potiche
et ils trouvent la potiche Le Pen.
Donc, Le Pen arrive
comme potiche en chef
pour parrainer les élections.
Seulement, Le Pen n'a pas
un tempérament de potiche
et il se trouve
qu'il est très bon orateur.
Il soulève les foules
et les salles et finalement,
c'est la potiche qui va prendre
le Front national,
et pas les autres.
-Une majorité des cadres
et jeunes militants
valident Jean-Marie Le Pen
comme leader politique
du Front national
pour l'unité française,
lancé le 5 octobre 1972 à Paris.
Ses statuts sont déposés
le 27 octobre 1972
à la préfecture de Paris
par Pierre Bousquet,
un ancien Waffen-SS.
-On a participé
à cette création
du Front national,
on a assuré la logistique
pour le Front national,
on faisait les collages,
les actions de médias
et autres...
C'est Le Pen qui est sorti du lot,
parce qu'effectivement,
il avait un charisme
et une culture extraordinaires.
Bon, on a avalisé Le Pen.
-Dans la perspective
des élections législatives de 1973,
le parti entreprend de constituer
un rassemblement
de la droite nationale,
alliant des anciens poujadistes
aux franges pétainistes
ou néonazis les plus extrêmes.
-Rassembler, rassembler,
rassembler,
c'était ça, quand même,
le leitmotiv
de mon action politique,
dans un monde très hostile.
-Le mouvement est apparu
comme la seule force organisée
de l'opposition nationale.
-Les dirigeants d'Ordre nouveau
François Duprat et Alain Robert
s'inspirent du modèle du MSI,
le parti néofasciste italien,
fondé en 1946
par des proches de Mussolini.
Se réclamant d'une droite sociale,
populaire, nationale,
le nouveau parti se veut être
une 3e voie
entre lutte des classes et monopole.
-Moi, je disais
qu'il n'y avait
de force politique réelle
que la force nationale
et qu'il fallait donc
organiser l'action politique
à partir de cette notion de base.
Ca a été l'histoire
du Front national.
-Le pari de Le Pen,
ça a été de la jouer
- passez-moi l'expression -
sur la durée,
de labourer le sillon,
inlassablement.
Il faut de la ténacité, pour ça.
Et il l'a eue.
-Lors de la présidentielle de 1974,
il se définit
comme le seul candidat de droite.
-On nous dit :
"Il faut voter,
quoi que nous pensions,
"pour M. Giscard d'Estaing.
"Certes, Jean-Marie Le Pen mène
depuis si longtemps
- comme si j'avais 90 ans -
"un combat courageux
et que nous respectons,
"mais hélas,
sans aucune chance,
"tandis que Giscard d'Estaing,
lui..."
-Donc, Le Pen se retrouve
avec 0,74 %,
la claque intégrale.
-Un bon moyen mnémotechnique :
0,74 en 74.
C'est inoubliable.
-Il tombe en dessous de 1 %,
mais ça a l'avantage
de le faire connaître,
et ça a aussi l'avantage
de le rendre légitime
comme représentant
de courant politique.
-J'ai dit : "Je ne céderai pas,
je ne m'arrêterai jamais,
"maintenant,
quels que soient les résultats."
J'ai entamé, alors là,
une traversée du désert
qui ne va cesser qu'en 1984.
-Une traversée du désert
qui s'annonce âpre
pour le chef
d'un parti sans le sou.
Un homme, Hubert Lambert,
rentier millionnaire,
est pourtant peut-être
en train de changer le destin
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
Il a fait de lui son héritier.
Lambert est alors membre
du comité central du FN.
Selon son médecin,
Hubert Lambert est fragile,
physiquement
et psychologiquement.
Il passe ses journées enfermés
chez lui avec sa mère, en pyjama,
à boire et fumer.
-Hubert et sa maman
m'ont choisi
comme légataire universel,
ce qui m'avait d'ailleurs
fait sourire et dire :
"Ecoutez, Hubert,
"tu m'as fait légataire universel,
"mais tu as cinq ans
de moins que moi.
"Je ne cours pas
de grands risques."
-Toutefois,
il décède très rapidement,
le 27 septembre 1976,
à l'âge de 42 ans.
Il lègue sa fortune
d'environ 18 millions d'euros
et l'hôtel particulier de Montretout
à Jean-Marie Le Pen.
-L'héritage Lambert,
beaucoup de militants rêvent,
à ce moment-là, se disent :
"Enfin, le parti va être riche."
Il y a des militants
du Front national, à l'époque,
qui, de leur poche,
payent le papier pour les tracts.
Les militants sont très investis
sur un parti qui est très pauvre,
mais en fait, l'héritage Lambert
va rester un bien privé,
une affaire privée.
-C'était quand même la volonté
de M. Lambert,
c'était de pouvoir donner
à Jean-Marie Le Pen
la possibilité
de faire de la politique,
parce que M. Lambert
croyait tout à fait
dans sa possibilité
de mener ce combat
pour la France,
et donc, de lui donner
les moyens financiers de le faire
sans être dépendant
de tel ou tel lobby
ou bien d'attendre...
Pour faire de la politique,
il faut les moyens de le faire.
-A peine deux mois plus tard,
le 2 novembre 1976,
un attentat à la bombe
détruit son domicile parisien.
Les 20 kg d'explosifs,
l'une des plus grosses charges
qu'ait connue Paris
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
détruisent une partie
de l'immeuble de 5 étages.
L'attentat est revendiqué
par un comité antifasciste.
-Je crois que la bombe
avait une intention criminelle,
l'intention de tuer,
de faire disparaître Le Pen
et sa famille.
Est-ce que c'était
pour des raisons privées
ou pour des raisons publiques ?
Je ne sais pas.
-Après des années de vaches maigres,
l'élection du socialiste
François Mitterrand
à la présidentielle de 1981
change radicalement
la donne politique.
Les municipales de 1983
sont historiques pour le FN.
Le Pen obtient 11,26 % des suffrages
dans le 20e secteur de Paris.
A Dreux, le Front national,
qui fusionne sa liste avec le RPR,
permet à la droite
de remporter la mairie.
Le secrétaire général du FN,
Jean-Pierre Stirbois,
en devient adjoint.
-J'ai dit tout haut ce que
les Drouais pensaient tout bas.
-Ce score et cette alliance sont,
pour le FN,
leur première victoire électorale
d'importance.
-C'est une brèche,
une petite brèche,
mais qui montre bien
l'état d'esprit, à l'époque,
de cette droite
qui est encore sous le choc
de l'arrivée au pouvoir
des socialistes en 81,
avec des ministres communistes,
à une époque où l'URSS
n'est pas encore tombée,
où le PC, c'est une courroie
de transmission de Moscou.
Cette droite est prête
à prendre tout le monde,
dans une grande union
des droites,
sauf qu'elle commet
une grosse erreur psychologique,
c'est de considérer que ces gens
sont des débris de l'histoire,
c'est ce qui reste
de la vieille extrême droite,
ils ne sont pas très malins,
"donc on va,
"nous, les notables de cette droite,
qui a un droit naturel à gouverner,
"les utiliser comme force d'appoint,
"et puis on aura naturellement
le dessus."
Mais non, en fait.
-C'est le début
des premiers succès électoraux
du Front national,
qui nous mettait tout de même
au rang des organisations politiques
qui devaient être prises
en considération,
et ça a été le début,
en quelque sorte,
du développement politique électoral
du Front national.
Thème de "L'heure de vérité"
-Jean-Marie Le Pen obtient
un accès croissant
à l'espace médiatique,
notamment avec son passage
à "L'heure de vérité",
le 13 février 1984,
sur demande
du président François Mitterrand.
-Bonsoir. Depuis la fin
de la guerre d'Algérie,
vous êtes devenu,
M. Le Pen,
un marginal du jeu politique...
-Quelques jours après l'émission,
le FN enregistre
un millier adhésions quotidiennes,
alors qu'il n'en recueillait
en moyenne que 15, jusqu'ici.
-Vous avez une existence électorale.
Vous faites partie de la réalité
de la société française.
C'est un fait et c'est pourquoi
je vous ai invité ce soir.
-Il fait un sans-faute,
et, surtout,
une espèce de mise en scène
où il se met debout
et il demande à la salle,
qui lui était tout acquise,
d'observer une minute de silence
à la mémoire
des victimes du communisme.
-Je voudrais me lever à mon tour
pour tenir une minute de silence
ou quelques instants de silence,
au moins,
en mémoire de tous ceux
qui sont tombés,
des dizaines de millions d'hommes,
tombés dans le monde
sous la dictature communiste
et avoir une pensée fraternelle
à l'égard des millions d'hommes
qui sont
dans les camps
et au goulag.
-Je suis journaliste, et je continue
à poser mes questions.
-Il y avait, sur le plateau,
les journalistes,
mais qui ne tenaient plus rien.
-Je voudrais poser une question
sur les restructurations
industrielles.
-Une minute de silence grandiose.
Le lendemain, ce n'est pas
une blague, je l'ai vu,
il y avait des milliers de demandes
d'inscription au Front national.
-Les élections européennes
qui suivent,
en juin 1984,
fonctionnent sur un mode
de scrutin proportionnel.
Les petits partis
sont représentés.
Le résultat ne se fait pas attendre.
Jean-Marie Le Pen
est élu député européen.
-Alors que Le Pen était,
avant, à 0,74,
il se retrouve aux élections
de juin 84,
les européennes, à 11 %.
-C'est 10 députés européens,
et à ce moment-là,
il est possible
de mieux structurer le mouvement,
de trouver des concours,
et ces concours vont permettre
d'améliorer matériellement
le siège du Front national,
et de commencer
à alimenter des permanents.
-C'est l'époque où apparaît le thème
de la préférence nationale,
une expression française forgée
en 1985
par Jean-Yves Le Gallou.
-La préférence nationale,
c'est quand même
une bonne manière
de limiter l'immigration,
tout simplement en supprimant
les pompes aspirant à l'immigration,
en faisant en sorte
que celui qui rentre
a un peu moins
d'intérêt à rentrer.
-Ca devient le programme du FN.
On voit bien, 1985,
le parti a été créé en 72,
et ce qui va devenir
la pierre angulaire de son programme
est un apport
d'autres courants politiques.
Jean-Yves Le Gallou
vient de la nouvelle droite.
Pour lui,
la question de la nationalité
est reliée
à la question de l'ethnicité.
-Le 16 mars 1986,
après le passage
au scrutin proportionnel
pour les législatives,
promesse de campagne
de François Mitterrand
permettant opportunément
d'atténuer une défaite,
le Front national fait son entrée
à l'Assemblée
et constitue un groupe
de 35 députés.
-Il décroche la timbale,
parce que là,
avec les 10 députés européens,
aux régionales,
133 ou 134 élus,
et puis, aux législatives,
un groupe de 35 députés.
Donc là, on passe vraiment
du stade embryonnaire
et de la fameuse traversée du désert
à l'irruption
sur la scène politique.
-C'est un vieux souvenir...
-L'émergence du Front national
sur le devant
de la scène politique française
pousse la droite à se positionner,
alors qu'un certain nombre
des cadres du Front national
vient des partis de droite
ou bien a travaillé avec eux.
-J'ai vu en Rhône-Alpes
des sections entières du RPR
qui m'ont rejoint,
qui ont rejoint le Front national.
Je pense à la section du RPR
de Vénissieux, par exemple,
troisième ville du Rhône.
-L'alliance semble désormais
la suite logique politique
entre le Front national
et le RPR.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen,
il a l'espoir de participer
à une coalition des droites.
En 1986,
selon un de ses amis,
il rêve que Jacques Chirac l'appelle
pour devenir ministre de la Défense.
-Ca paraissait évident,
pour tout le monde,
et c'est là
qu'on tombe sur Chirac.
Chirac, tout seul,
qui refuse absolument.
Niet, niet, niet.
-Le succès d'une force nouvelle
est toujours attractive
aux yeux de l'opinion.
Ca a provoqué un phénomène de rejet
des organisations existantes
et une espèce
de pacte de diabolisation
et de refus de collaboration,
comme j'avais essayé
de la démontrer possible
lors de l'élection de 86, justement,
en recrutant,
à côté
des Front national proprement dit,
des gens
qui étaient très proches de nous,
mais qui appartenaient
aux milieux libéraux
de la droite classique,
en quelque sorte,
et la réaction nous a été hostile,
et elle s'est traduite évidemment
par un blocage
de notre progression politique.
-Jacques Chirac a senti
tout de suite
que le Front national
ne se destinait pas
à un rôle de supplétif,
et que ces gens,
si on s'alliait avec eux,
c'était le baiser de la mort.
-Pourtant, Le Pen travaille dur
à l'amélioration de son image
en vue de la présidentielle de 1988.
Il rencontre
des politiques étrangers.
Aux Etats-Unis, Ronald Reagan,
dont il se veut le pendant français.
Il se fait même applaudir
par d'anciens membres
du Congrès juif mondial
pour un discours pro-israélien.
Cette campagne
est remise en cause,
le 13 septembre 1987,
lorsqu'il affirme
que les chambres à gaz
sont un détail de l'histoire
de la 2nde Guerre mondiale.
-Je suis passionné par l'histoire
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Je me pose un certain nombre
de questions.
Je ne dis pas que les chambres à gaz
n'ont pas existé.
Je n'ai pas pu moi-même en voir,
je n'ai pas étudié spécialement
la question,
mais je crois
que c'est un point de détail
de l'histoire
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
-C'est tout le caractère
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
Il va refuser de se dédire.
Il va au contraire en rajouter,
il va répéter le point de détail.
-Pour moi, les chambres à gaz,
c'est un détail de l'histoire.
Ce qui est une évidence !
Si ce n'est pas un détail
de l'histoire, c'est quoi ?
Comment peut-on l'apprécier ?
L'histoire est faite
d'une multiplicité de détails,
dont certains sont essentiels,
d'autres sont secondaires,
mais qui constituent l'ensemble.
Il n'y avait absolument
aucune affirmation politique,
au contraire.
Je traitais l'affaire
avec un relatif dédain.
Je demandais ce que venait faire
cette affaire
dans le débat
qui nous intéressait.
C'est un détail de l'histoire
de la 2e Guerre mondiale.
-Ces propos,
maintenus aujourd'hui,
entraînent le départ
de sympathisants,
de militants et cadres
du Front national,
ainsi que la réprobation
de la quasi-totalité
de la classe politique.
-Pour moi, c'est très simple,
il n'a plus jamais été en position
de vraiment parvenir au pouvoir.
Parce que l'exclusion
qui a été signifiée avant
trouvait là
une justification colossale.
-Après, si vous voulez,
pour rétablir
un minimum de confiance,
de crédibilité vis-à-vis
de la droite,
dite parlementaire ou conservatrice,
il faut y aller à la rame,
parce que très clairement,
la question du point de détail a été
une sorte de ligne rouge
qui rendait véritablement
l'hypothèse d'une alliance,
même locale,
avec les partis de droite
strictement infaisable.
-Au soir du premier tour,
le 24 avril 1988,
il obtient 14,4 % des voix,
un score supérieur
à ce que présageaient les sondages.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen,
14,4...
-Ce score inattendu met Chirac
dans une situation délicate.
-L'affaire du détail,
c'était censé traumatiser
le monde politique
et censé dévoiler
la face hideuse
d'un fascisme renaissant, etc.,
mais M. Chirac rencontrera
Jean-Marie Le Pen
entre les deux tours
sans se souvenir du détail
ou sans lui accorder
la moindre importance.
La priorité étant
que Le Pen appelle
à voter contre François Mitterrand.
-Chirac était extrêmement nerveux.
Avant même toute chose, il dit :
"Je ne peux pas accepter
ça, ça et ça."
"Si vous n'acceptez
ni ça, ni ça, ni ça,
"il n'y a aucune raison
"que nous ayons quelque contact
que ce soit.
"Par conséquent,
"ne comptez pas sur nous
pour vous servir d'alibi."
Voilà, ça a mené à une politique
de non-coopération.
*-Nous avons besoin d'un homme
qui aux idées claires.
-Jacques Chirac a besoin
des voix de Le Pen
pour l'emporter face à Mitterrand.
Sans pour autant conclure
un accord formel,
côté RPR, on laisse entrevoir
un possible retour
de la proportionnelle
en échange d'un appel
à ne pas voter Mitterrand.
-Certes, Chirac ne sera pas élu,
mais Le Pen tiendra sa parole.
Son discours est très clair,
il dit :
"Non, non, non, pas une voix
"pour François Mitterrand."
Voilà.
-"Quant au candidat résiduel
de la droite,
"faites ce que vous voudrez,
sous votre responsabilité."
"Candidat résiduel de la droite",
il est certain que les électeurs
n'ont pas été tentés
de soutenir Jacques Chirac,
qui sera battu,
et Mitterrand réélu, à plus de 53 %.
-Les scrutins à la proportionnelle
ou incluant une dose
de proportionnelle
ne feront jamais
leur retour.
-L'adversaire nous a mis
tous les bâtons possibles
dans les roues,
et en l'occurrence,
n'a jamais rétabli
la proportionnelle,
qui permettait au Front national
d'exister sur le plan national,
de faire connaître ses idées,
ses choix, ses opinions,
ses solutions.
Et donc, on l'a stérilisé,
en quelque sorte.
-En conséquence, Le Pen change
radicalement de stratégie
vis-à-vis de la droite classique.
-Ca va permettre à Le Pen
de se venger
de la parole trahie
au niveau
de la proportionnelle.
Et là, tout en continuant
de participer aux élections,
il va avoir un combat
beaucoup plus fort
contre la droite
et contre la gauche,
c'est-à-dire,
ce n'est plus
la volonté d'être
une force d'appoint de la droite,
c'est une 3e force
qu'il n'hésitera pas à faire battre
des candidats de droite
dans certaines circonstances.
-Après avoir été membre du RPR,
puis présidé son propre mouvement,
les Comités d'action républicaine,
Bruno Mégret rejoint
le Front national en 1987.
Jean-Marie Le Pen
le nomme directeur
de sa campagne présidentielle
pour 1988
et son influence
ne cesse de grandir
au sein du FN.
En octobre 1988,
il est nommé délégué général
du Front national.
-C'était un polytechnicien,
c'était un homme intelligent,
tout à fait fréquentable.
Il a occupé des fonctions
qui correspondaient à ses capacités.
-Mais il y a effectivement
chez Mégret
une capacité d'ordre,
de réflexion,
de mise en ordre des dossiers,
d'organisation des blocs,
qui est très bonne.
C'était un binôme
qui fonctionnait fort bien.
Vous aviez le général en chef
et le chef d'état-major.
-En plus,
il a une équipe efficace.
L'argument "je vais
professionnaliser le Front National
"comme il ne l'a jamais été" :
il met en place des structures
à la fois intellectuelles et
techniques qui n'existaient pas.
-En juin 1989,
Mégret est élu
au Parlement européen.
A partir d'octobre 1990,
il est, de surcroît,
le leader du FN,
dans la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte-d'Azur.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen
a toujours su
équilibrer les courants du parti.
Exemple : à la formation,
il met les chefs de file
des nationaux-catholiques
et des néo-païens,
deux courants complètement opposés
travaillant ensemble.
Il a utilisé les uns
contre les autres.
Jean-Pierre Stirbois avait pris
un gigantesque poids dans le parti :
Jean-Marie Le Pen lui met
Bruno Mégret dans les pattes.
Quand Bruno Mégret va monter,
à un moment,
Jean-Marie Le Pen
va jouer Carl Lang.
Il est l'arbitre,
mais si vous prenez trop de place,
il met quelqu'un
dans vos pattes.
-Peu à peu, Bruno Mégret s'impose
comme numéro 2 du Front National
et forge son image.
Ainsi, il fonde, en 1989,
la revue Identité,
qui va organiser et mettre en forme
le corpus idéologique
de l'extrême droite française.
-Bruno Mégret a réellement
mis en place,
à l'intérieur
de l'appareil frontiste,
ses propres réseaux,
répondant à leurs propres objectifs
stratégiques,
qui ne sont pas toujours convergents
avec ceux de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
-Le Pen fait une erreur
de psychologie :
il pense que Mégret
ne passera pas à l'acte.
Il sait tout, évidemment,
des projets de Mégret, du noyautage,
de l'intervention
dans l'organisation
à un niveau croissant,
la maîtrise de l'appareil, etc.
Mais à cette époque, d'une part,
Jean-Marie Le Pen est
un chef incontesté,
et il pense que Mégret
n'a aucune chance
de réussir son opération,
et qu'il est assez intelligent
pour ne pas la tenter.
Jusqu'au bout,
Le Pen a, je pense,
cru cela : c'est que Mégret
comprendrait qu'il ne peut pas
affronter Jean-Marie Le Pen
et s'en sortir.
Musique à suspense
-Il y a un affrontement larvé
entre les deux hommes,
au sujet
des concessions impliquées par
la stratégie de conquête du pouvoir.
...
Bruno Mégret propose,
pour y arriver,
une alliance
avec le RPR et l'UDF,
à la condition que le FN soit
en position dominante.
...
-Bruno Mégret a fait
espérer - il le pensait sans doute,
d'ailleurs, lui-même -
que lui parviendrait à s'entendre
avec le RPR et l'UDF.
Il a fait miroiter
un certain nombre de cas :
"Si vous êtes
conseiller municipal,
"vous allez devenir un élu
départemental ou régional,
"si vous êtes élu régional,
"vous allez devenir député, etc."
Hélas,
il a, à partir de qualités
absolument indéniables,
entraîné beaucoup de gens
dans cette opération.
-J'entends dire...
-Mais pour Le Pen,
la seule voie possible
est celle de Le Pen,
c'est-à-dire l'élection du chef
à la présidentielle.
-Ce que nous voulons,
c'est la puissance.
-Le Pen considérait qu'au FN,
il n'y avait pas de numéro 2.
Un numéro 1.
Et ça, c'est sans doute
une erreur.
L'autre erreur,
je crois qu'il l'a commise
en pensant que le pouvoir ne pouvait
se conquérir que par le haut.
-Dans les vraies divergences de fond
entre Le Pen et Mégret,
en dehors d'une différence de style
incontestable, il y avait
le poids à donner à l'enracinement
territorial ou pas.
Mégret était plutôt
de ce côté-là,
Jean-Marie Le Pen
était quand même
l'homme de l'élection
présidentielle,
qui était un peu présentée
comme la mère des batailles.
-Bonsoir.
L'après-municipales,
avec l'enracinement
du Front National...
-Pourtant, c'est aux municipales
de 1995
que le FN s'envole.
Pour la première fois,
il obtient des mairies,
à Toulon,
à Orange et Marignane.
-Le Pen jalousait,
évidemment, les réussites
et les succès
qu'il y avait
au niveau local,
et qui ne suivaient pas
au niveau national.
-Voici le choix
des français...
-Si Le Pen améliore son score
à la présidentielle
de 1995, il arrive seulement
en quatrième position,
avec 15 % des voix,
derrière Lionel Jospin,
Jacques Chirac et Edouard Balladur.
-Le temps passe.
Il a 67 ans, en 1995.
Et
il comprend très bien que là, il va
en prendre pour sept ans de Chirac,
Que, donc, il aura 74 ans,
à la prochaine échéance.
-Fort de ses succès, Mégret amplifie
son emprise sur le FN
et commence à presser
l'entourage de Le Pen
pour qu'il passe enfin la main.
-C'est être calife
à la place du calife.
Un peu, quand même.
Mais c'était sans connaître
Jean-Marie Le Pen,
parce que ça couvait,
quand même.
Il y avait quand même
des approches qui étaient faites,
très habilement,
je dois reconnaître.
Au bout d'un moment,
vous vous demandiez :
"Pourquoi il me demande tout ça ?"
On essayait de faire critiquer
la gestion du parti
par Jean-Marie Le Pen.
On le traitait d'autoritaire
et on disait : "A son âge !"
Alors imaginez, aujourd'hui !
"A son âge,
"il devrait passer la main !"
Déjà, à l'époque !
-Je pense que Mégret considérait
que la dernière campagne
de Jean-Marie Le Pen
devait être 1995,
que son tour viendrait,
à Bruno Mégret, en 2002.
Donc, il fallait faire quelque chose
entre-temps,
et Le Pen avait franchi
l'âge limite de 65 ans.
Pour les fonctionnaires,
65 ans, c'est la retraite.
-Il met en oeuvre
une stratégie de dédiabolisation,
pour permettre
l'accession au pouvoir.
Il se montre ouvert à des alliances
avec la droite parlementaire.
Dans le même temps,
Le Pen perd le soutien
de cadres du parti,
qui regrettent
son manque
d'implication dans les élections
législatives et locales.
-Si vous réussissez
à amener la droite
à signer les contrats
de mandature,
vous vous légitimez !
Vous vous légitimez d'autant plus,
si vous savez, ensuite,
montrer que vous pouvez être
des gestionnaires corrects.
Vous vous légitimez
si vous réussissez à être
à la fois dans une certaine forme
de radicalité politique
et si, en même temps,
vous réussissez à naviguer
entre les écueils
du politiquement correct.
Et ça, Jean-Marie Le Pen
sait pas faire.
-J'étais pas en position de subir
des exigences internes au mouvement
de qui que ce soit.
A aucun moment.
J'avais une autorité
dans le mouvement
qui ne permettait pas
de faire quoi que ce soit
en dehors de mon accord
ou de mon autorisation.
Cris
-Le conflit se cristallise
autour des élections européennes
de 1999.
Condamné à 2 ans d'inéligibilité
pour avoir
agressé une candidate PS,
Le Pen confie,
en juillet 1998,
la direction de la liste du FN
à sa femme, Jany,
et non à son numéro 2,
pourtant au zénith de son influence.
Bruno Mégret, humilié,
dévoile alors ses ambitions
et déclare que la candidature
de Jany Le Pen
n'est pas une bonne idée.
-Et au moment
où Le Pen voit
que les choses se gâtent,
il y aura un prétexte :
la mise à l'écart de salariés
de Bruno Mégret,
qui étaient très actifs,
pour empêcher Jean-Marie Le Pen
d'être le prochain candidat
à la présidentielle
pour le FN.
Donc, il prend l'initiative
de commencer à affaiblir Mégret,
notamment en lui retirant
des moyens matériels, etc.,
ce qui va convaincre
les amis de Mégret
de passer à l'acte.
-MEGRET PRESIDENT !
-La crise atteint son paroxysme,
le 5 décembre 1998,
lors du conseil national
qui réunit les 300 responsables
les plus importants du parti
pour préparer les européennes.
Les mégrétistes font éclater
la contestation au grand jour
et conspuent Le Pen.
-Jean-Marie, tu déconnes !
Acclamations
et applaudissements
...
-C'était pas
une journée marrante,
le 5 novembre 1998, loin de là.
Quand on est arrivés
à cette grande réunion,
à la Maison de la Chimie,
c'est vrai que vous sentiez,
à l'arrivée, qu'il y avait
un truc qui allait se passer.
Car les gens...
il y avait une effervescence...
Il y avait une violence
sous-jacente, déjà. Puis,
voilà, ça s'est déclenché,
et Le Pen, à ce moment-là,
a réagi...
C'était quitte ou double.
C'était quitte ou double, parce que,
quand vous avez un putsch...
"Puputsch" !
Mais à l'époque,
ça ressemblait
à un putsch tout court,
en direct, comme ça,
on n'en connaît pas l'issue.
Et Le Pen a réagi,
alors vraiment...
à sa façon, c'est-à-dire
de façon extrêmement claire,
en les foutant dehors.
-Cela provoque
la révocation de Mégret
de la délégation générale
du parti,
puis son exclusion,
le 23 décembre 1998.
Pour le FN de Le Pen,
c'est une saignée.
-Ce qui fait que, voilà,
il y a eu cette scission, qui était
une catastrophe pour le Front,
car, d'un côté, Le Pen reste
avec son nom,
avec sa gueule,
avec son histoire,
avec ses capacités,
et donc, le gros des électeurs
va aller à Le Pen,
et de l'autre côté,
vous avez les cadres,
l'organisation, qui va avec Mégret.
Donc, cette espèce
d'équilibre du Front
est complètement rompu, et mettra
des années et des années à...
S'il s'en est jamais remis.
A mon avis,
il ne s'en est pas remis.
-Après ses dérapages
des années 80 et 90,
cette scission hypothèque
de nouveau sérieusement
sa prochaine candidature
à l'élection présidentielle,
même si l'ancien leader
du Front National ne regrette rien.
-La rupture du Front
a été un coup terrible,
mais je ne regrette pas
d'avoir eu les positions
que j'ai eues à ce moment-là.
-Sur le plan électoral,
la sanction est immédiate :
aux européennes qui suivent,
le parti de Mégret
ne dépasse pas les 4 %,
tandis que Le Pen ne parvient
à faire élire que cinq députés.
-Et tout cela a débouché
sur un gâchis monumental,
c'est-à-dire
des résultats très mauvais
pour les deux mouvements :
le Front à 5 % aux européennes,
en 1999,
Mégret, 3 %.
Mais Le Pen restera sonné
par cette scission,
dans la mesure
où il ne retrouvera jamais
l'implantation qui avait fait
les heures de gloire
du Front National
dans les années 1990.
Cris de dépit
-Fort de ces mauvais résultats
et d'un parti
exsangue,
la surprise est d'autant plus grande
pour les observateurs
et le principal intéressé.
Cette élection constitue
un événement important
de la vie politique française :
la 1re fois
qu'un candidat classé
à l'extrême droite
se qualifie pour le 2d tour.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen
en direct...
-Mais le traditionnel débat
n'a pas lieu : Jacques Chirac
refuse de débattre avec lui
et 500 000 Français manifestent.
Mais au-delà de ces événements,
Le Pen était-il vraiment
en mesure de prendre
le pouvoir ?
-Vous faites 17 % des voix
à la présidentielle,
vous accédez au 2d tour :
vous avez fait
le plein de vos voix.
Vous avez,
dans la population française,
dans l'électorat français,
cet étiage-là.
Seulement, la présidentielle,
c'est 50 % des voix plus une,
pour la gagner,
et le rapport de force
n'y est pas.
Effectivement, on a pu dire,
et c'est une réalité,
que Le Pen lui-même n'avait pas
anticipé sa présence au 2nd tour,
que le parti n'avait pas de matériel
de campagne pour le 2d tour
dans les tiroirs, que la machine
n'était pas assez puissante
pour mettre le turbo
entre les 2 tours,
mais ça aurait pas changé
grand-chose s'il l'avait eu.
La vérité, c'est que,
quand vous êtes
une famille politique
qui représente zéro en 1974
que vous êtes à 17 %
en 2002,
vous avez déjà fait
un énorme travail
et vous avez atteint
votre plafond.
-Faiblesses structurelles,
plafond de voix atteint,
et le candidat voulait-il
le pouvoir ?
Y croyait-il vraiment ?
Etait-il prêt à rassembler
le plus grand nombre ?
-Jean-Marie Le Pen
a-t-il voulu le pouvoir ?
Je crois que oui.
Je crois qu'il l'a voulu ardemment,
en 1965.
Il l'a re-voulu en 1984,
1986, 1987,
jusqu'à l'élection de 1995.
Il a été scié
par l'élection de Chirac,
qui était l'homme
qui a actualisé
le piège de Mitterrand.
Sans Chirac, le piège de Mitterrand
ne marche pas.
Je pense qu'à partir de 1995,
je ne sais pas, consciemment,
s'il s'est dit :
"Allez, je vais jouer
pour ne pas avoir le pouvoir",
mais je crois qu'il a perdu l'espoir
d'arriver au pouvoir,
et qu'il a, donc,
continué à jouer le rôle
d'un très bon chef de parti,
par moments,
d'autres fois moins bon,
après, on le discute ou pas,
mais, oui,
la cassure, c'est 1995.
Musique douce
...
-Si, pour élargir
la base de l'électorat
il faut changer les idées
que l'on croit justes,
en effet, je ne suis pas
suffisamment manoeuvrier,
suffisamment malin
et, surtout, je n'ai pas
comme objectif principal
mon succès personnel,
dans ce cas, donc, je ne fais pas
le sacrifice de principes
au bénéfice de succès électoraux.
Voilà.
Néanmoins,
j'assume la responsabilité
des échecs éventuels
qui peuvent être liés au respect
d'un certain nombre de valeurs
que je considère
comme incontournables.
-On entend souvent de Le Pen
que l'homme n'a pas gagné,
mais que ses idées ont triomphé,
qu'elles imprègnent aujourd'hui
la société française.
-Jean-Marie Le Pen n'a pas
entièrement gagné
la bataille des idées :
la France est toujours
dans l'Union Européenne,
nous accueillons encore
des demandeurs d'asile,
il existe encore
une immigration légale
et un certain nombre de réformes
sociétales ont vu le jour.
Donc, non,
les idées n'ont pas triomphé,
Et d'autres idées
sont apparues aussi,
que les jeunes
générations non-frontistes portent,
et que le Front National
n'arrive pas à capter,
notamment les sujets liés
à l'urgence environnementale.
Mais la petite musique
sur l'immigration et sur l'identité,
oui, incontestablement,
elle a largement contribué
à faire qu'aujourd'hui
ces thèmes soient repris,
non seulement par ceux
que l'on situe à l'extrême droite,
même à l'intérieur de la droite.
-Cinq fois candidat
de l'extrême droite
à une présidentielle,
Le Pen s'est hissé par trois fois
en 4e position du premier tour
puis, à la surprise générale,
au second tour de celle de 2002.
Sa fille, Marine Le Pen, lui succède
en 2011, à la présidence du parti,
quand il devient
président d'honneur,
avant d'en être exclu,
en 2015.
Le Pen a été la figure de proue
du Front National,
un assemblage de constellations
politiques complexes,
aux intérêts et aux idéaux
parfois contradictoires,
mais aussi un trait d'union
entre diverses familles
de l'extrême droite,
des admirateurs de Vichy
aux catholiques intégristes
nationalistes,
en passant par les nostalgiques
de l'Algérie française,
les anti-communistes
et les défenseurs
des laissés-pour-compte
de la modernité.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...